universel euh ce weekend une photo
publiée sur X ça fait polémique on y
voit un groupe d'une trentaine de
personnes en train de faire la prière
dans un terminal de l'aéroport de roissi
Charles de Gaulle à Paris on vous
explique tout et vous nous dites ce que
vous en pensez est-ce que vous êtes
choqué ou pas par cette vidéo qui a fait
énormément parler regardez cette photo
qui effectivement agite les réseaux
sociaux depuis hier après-midi
maintenant regardez on est à l'aéroport
roissi charles- de Gaulle et ces
passagers sont en train de faire une
prière une prière collective musulmane
on est plus particulièrement dans une
salle d'embarquement dans le terminal de
B alors cette photo elle a été postée
sur Twitter par Noël l noir qui était
ministre des Affaires étrangères sous
Jacques Chirac elle interpelle le PDG
des aéroports de Paris en lui demandant
si l'aéroport se transforme en mosquée
le PDG des aéroports de Paris a rappelé
que la police aux frontières devait
interdire cela et lui demande de
redoubler de vigilance alors est-ce que
vous êtes choqué oui non c'est notre
débat du jour également vous réagissez
chez vous il les 19h57 on est en direct
Gill verdz non pas du tout euh je vais
pas dire que je trouve ça très bien
parce que légalement il y a des lieux de
prière dans le Terminal 1 le terminal 2
de Roissy donc ils auraient pu ils
auraient dû y aller mais enfin ça choque
qui et je trouve que euh les stigmatiser
les mettre en photo en vidéo comme ça
euh c'est de l'islamophobie quoi voilà
moi ça ne me dérange pas ils allaient à
la mec c'est des pèlerins ils peuvent
prier qui ça dérange personne voilà ça
vous dérange pas vous non moi ça me
dérange pas ça me dérange pas parce que
comme le dit Gill en fait le seul truc
c'est que oui il pouvait le faire bien
sûr en intimité parce qu' il y a des
endroits approprié à ça mais après moi
je trouve que là le monde part tellement
en ququette et que il y a rien qui va
que là je vois une image de paix et
d'amour et ben ça me dérange pas parce
que bah parce que la religion que ce
soit n'importe laquelle c'est de la paix
et de l'amour et ça vous dérange vous
moi moi c'est pas choqué parce qu' a
marqué choqué je suis pas choqué je suis
pas d'accord parce que je eux ne me
dérange pas il y a personne dans dans
l'aéroport mais il y a des salles qui
sont prévues pour ça il l'a dit donc on
fait dans les salles qui sont prévu pour
ça parce que si demain vous avez 300
personnes qui font des prières comme ça
parce qu'on l'a laissé faire c'est moi
moi je suis pas c'est pas choquant mais
je ne suis pas d'accord parce que c'est
pas l'endroit pour faire la prière ici
il y a des salles pour faire des prières
pas dans les lieux publics ça je suis
d'accord avec toi mais là apparemment
pas dans ce ce terminal là précisément
donc il aurait fallu qu'ils aillent
beaucoup plus loin pour essayerouver la
salle en et moi moi moi pourquoi je dis
non aussi c'est parce que je pense que
en ce moment il faut arrêter de enfin
faut essayer de pas instrumentaliser
toutes les images possibles pour essayer
de faire monter les camps les un contre
les autres pour essayer de mettre de la
tension partout et donc j'ai peur qu'à
chaque fois qu'on est qu'on est une
image on essaie de l'inrumentalis je su
comme toi mais s'il y a 200 ou 300
personnes tu ser
d'accord ils font pas la prière pour
bonne raison c'est que là il ne cause
pas de trouble public premièrement et
quand tu regardes bien j'ai un ami à moi
qui travaille justement dans ce terminal
que j'ai eu je lui dis est-ce que la
mais là attendez
attende d'accordors je fais comme vous
alors je fais comme vous ça y est
arrêtez de me faire chier je fais comme
vouss
pour c'est trop facile parce que ce
terminal là la question c'est dans
l'éropor
mec sinon on arrête ça fait 7 ans que tu
travailles ici tu me coupes la parole je
suis lundi ou mardi laisse-moi finir tu
me coupes laisse-moi finir ma livraison
laisse-moi finir ma livraison comme ça
tu l laisse-moi finir d'accord ça me
choque pas pourquoi il ne cause pas
d'ordre à au trouble public ça c'est la
première chose la seconde chose et ça je
vais te dire à toi bien évidemment mon
mon cher ami c'est que ouais c'est Ron
c'est mon ami Déclaration des Droits de
l'Homme 1789 on était pas né tous les
deux nul ne doit être inquiété pour ses
opinions même religie je sais écr oui
exactement pourvu que la manifestation
ne trouble pas l'ordre public là je te
répète avant que tu t'énerves c'est rare
en plus donc pour le coup j'appelle un
ami qui travaille là-bas je lui dis
écoute parce que même moi je me suis dit
à mon avis ils ont dû prendre soit les
douigners soit les flics sachant que
dans les aéroport avec ce qui se passe
le plan Vig pirate il suffit de la
moindre chose ça débarque de tous les
côtés donc qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il
m'a dit il ne causait absolument pas il
y avait même des douaniers qui sont
passés et qui n'ont rien dit maintenant
là où je te rejoins là où je te rejoins
parce que je prie Mo aussi donc
effectivement je préfère prier dans une
salle dans unité l'autre mais là en plus
c'est c'est un groupe qui part pour un
pèlerinage et à mon avis mais tu as même
les dames qui prient même les vieilles
personnes qui peuvent pas s'allonger et
qui sont sur siège et qui et qui pri ils
ont vu qu'il y avait personne en face tu
vois bien que le le le truc est vide
question c'est une prière collective
dans un terminal de l'aéroport de
roissie est-ce que vous êtes choqué je
choqué non je ne suis pas d'accord la
question c'est pas ils ont fait au
terminal 6 la prochaine salle de prière
la prochaine salle de prière elle est à
420 km là ils sont 20 ils font de pas
trouble à l'ORD de public la question
c'est-ce que vous acceptez compris dans
un aéroport comme ça même s'ils sont 400
dans un autre jour puisqu'on les a
laissé eux prier est-ce que vous
acceptez qu'après quand ils vont être
300 400 est-ce que vous accepter qu'
pris dans un aéroport ma question c'est
non si c'est pour dire c'est pas
l'aéroport c'est pas ceci c'est pas cela
et là ils avaient le droit et là ils
avaient pas le droit je fais comme vous
je pas mes couilles et je fais comme
vous non tu gueules pour rien
Ren comme vous pas de politique continue
à livrer mais questiontique je fais
comm c'est non c'est non ils ont raison
ils ont le
droit je suis d'accord avec je suis
d'accord avec Raymon moi je suis pas
choquée parce que je trouve que ça a
l'air très calme très apaisé mais moi je
ne veux absolument pas et et ça je
n'aime pas qu'on voit la religion la
religion c'est quelque chose d'intime de
privé il y a des salles pour ça dans les
aéroports quelle que soit sa religion et
moi je je voudrais à ce moment-là que
tous les gens qui prient et on en voit
de temps en temps dans les aéroports
aillent aillent dans les salles qui sont
à cet usage voilà et et je trouve Queen
fait je suis d'accord avec Valérie et je
suis d'accord avec Ellie que aujourd'hui
instrumentaliser cette image pour encore
comment dire euh jeter un sorte de de de
d'image un peu dégradante ou négative
sur telle ou telle communauté ça me
déplaît mais je ne veux pas compris dans
un aéroport voilà quelle que soit la
religion pour toutes les religions
attention fa pas dire ce que j'ai pas
dire demain je vois des rabats des Juifs
pr comme ça je vais pas être content non
plus c'est pareil pour tout le monde ça
arrive moi je catholque parond moi je
suis catholique et quand je prie j' non
mais quand moi je suis catholique je
prie mais ça n'intéresse personne donc
je pars du principe que tout le monde
parce que c'est un espace public doit
faire la même chose je condamne pas du
tout cette image effectivement c'était
c'était un moment de prière mais je
rejoins aussi l'idée effectivement on
ferait quoi s'il y avait 300 400 500
personnes oui mais qui se mettaient à
prier vais vous don toérance moi je vais
vous donner une de tolér j'ai pris 135 €
d'amende tu sais pourquoi je voulais
rentrer dans un porche je voulais je
voulais rentrer dans un Porsche je
voulais rentrer dans un Porsche j'ai dit
au mec tu peux avancer ton camion parce
que je rentre dans un porche collègue il
est descendu il m'a dit il peut pas
bouger parce qu'il fait la prière il
était au volant de son camion j'ai dit
d'accord pas de problème il est au
volant de son camion il fait sa prière
ça va durer 5 minutes tu es d'accord
avec moi ou pas il peut pas bouger son
camion il est en train de faire la
prière j'ai pris la vidéo surveillance
135 € je m'en fous des 135 € il a fait
la prière il est en paix il travaille il
a fait sa prière il est en paix il y a
pas de souci j'ai pris me faites pas
dire des trucs que j'ai ne pas dit M si
vous TR c'est toi qui t'éner tout seul
c'est toi qui t'éner tout seul mais non
mais tu étais pas là mais c'est pas la
première émission où on pose des
questions et les gens disent oui mais
parce que les
mecs pouro vous me mettez dans le
merdier là j'ai rien dit moi c'est parce
que ce so même quand tu dis rien pe
pas même quand tu dis rien elle peut pas
te bérer Géraldine Géraldine Géraldine
d'abord je blare infiniment Gill Verdez
mais juste parce que évidemment Raymon a
raison ce soir sur les réseaux il y aura
marqué Raymon et Géral moi j'ai
l'habitude islamophobe voilà donc en
fait on n peut plus de ça en fait parce
qu'on est dans un monde à cause des
réseaux sociaux sans nuance où on est
forcément dans un camp ou dans l'autre
il s'agit pas d'être dans un camp ou
dans l'autre il s'agit d'être dans un
pays où on ne montre pas sa religion et
quand on veut et qu'on respecte la loi
mais la loi pour moi et la loi c'est
quoi mais c'est pas d'aller prier
n'impor o n'imp comment il dit la lo
c'est trouble alord de public
il donc tu as le droit de dire que tu as
tu as le droit de dire que ceux qui sont
en équilibre avec leur foi ils doivent
faire leur foi dans dans les lieux de
culte d'accord parce que nous il nous
arrive pendant mois du Ramadan par
exemple où les mosquées sont blindées on
est obligé de prier dehors parce que
c'est blindé ou alors on va on va
attends attends ou alors on va on va
dans les stades ce que je trouve ce que
je trouve honteux d'accord on doit avoir
des lie de cultes effectivement là ça a
été très bref mais je peux comprendre
aussi que ça si c'est blindé c'est bien
qu'on te laisse rentrer dans un stade si
les mosquées sont blindé en temps de
Ramadan c'est quand même bien qu'on te
laisse rentrer dans un stade c'est ça
que tu tu me parles du Ramadan bien sûr
Ramadan c'est tolérance je te dis
honnêtement je pense que tu es mieux
livreur que ça ça fait TR fois que tu
fais la vanne ça fait 7 ans que je suis
là dis-moi toi tu tu défend la
dismoii bien sûr que je suis mieux
livreur bien sûr que mais ça n'empêche
pas que j'ai le droit de donner mon avis
mais tu as le droit de donner ton avis
mais tu gueules ch j'aimerais qu'on voie
le sondage s'il vous plaît avant d'avoir
le le reste de la table 80 % des gens
sont choqués 80 % Bernard Montiel fait
partie de ces 80 % pourquoi oui moi je
trouve ça formidable des gens qui prient
et qui qui ont la foi quoi qu'il en soit
ça me gêne parce que c'est un pays c'est
c'est un pays c'est un pays nous sommes
en France c'est un pays laïque je
comprends que cette image puisse
surprendre en plus elle est toujours
utilisée à dessin c'està-dire pour
stigmatiser les musulmans et c'est ça
que je regrette
Cho pas
Cho dis c'est
dérant en public comme ça je répète
c'est un pays la de faites
ouime rpond une question es
ch qui vont faire une prière à choque
pas
[Rires]
ch je suis pas choqué pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que ça n'arrive jamais il
y a une salle de prière juste avant le
filtre et la plupart du temps les gens
vont prier à la dans la salle de prière
et ensuite là j'imagine que l'avion a dû
avoir du retard et que c'était l'heure
de la prière ils ont prié pour cette
raison ou non c'est la réalité ça
n'arrive
jamaise une question un TR je suis très
je pense qu' un moment donné il faut
aussi choisir entreilletses combats et
stigmatiser les 15
personnes de dire ce que je suis en
train de dire et donc je veux dire que
l'utilisation de cette image me dérange
plus que la prière en elle même mais je
suis évidemment pas pour ces prières
comme ça n'importe où et évidemment que
je suis que je préfère que les Prières a
lieu dans des
espaces
comm